♪ ♪
>> Sean: NOW A SHOCKING STORY
OUT OF HAITI TONIGHT WHERE
PRESIDENT WAS ASSASSINATED BY A
SQUAD OF GUNMEN AND HIS WIFE
WOUNDED IN AN OVERNIGHT RATE AT
THEIR HOME.
THE KILLING HAS SPARKED UNREST,
CHAOS, CONFUSION, IN A COUNTRY
THAT IS ALREADY GRAPPLING WITH
VIOLENT CRIME AND POVERTY IN
PROTESTS AGAINST AUTHORITARIAN
RULE.
WE WILL HAVE MORE STRAIGHT AHEAD
BUT ALSO TONIGHT IRAN IS RAISING
MORE CONCERNS AFTER THEY NOW SAY
THEY HAVE FURTHER ENRICHED THEIR
URANIUM.
STATE APARTMENT SPOKESPERSON NED
PRICE SAID IT WAS "ANOTHER
UNFORTUNATE STEP BACKWARDS."
WELL, ACTUALLY, IT'S MORE
PREDICTABLE THAN UNFORTUNATE.
THIS IS WHAT A WEAK FOREIGN
POLICY BEGETS.
IT EMBOLDENS OUR ENEMIES.
BUT REMEMBER, IF THIS IT
ADMINISTRATION, THEY WANT TO GO
BACK TO THE MOST INSANE IRANIAN
NUCLEAR DEAL EVER AND WANT TO GO
BACK TO THE STATUS QUO AND NOT
HOLD TEHRAN ACCOUNTABLE FOR ITS
EXPORT OF TERROR AS THE WORLD'S
NUMBER ONE STATE SPONSOR OF
TERRORISM AND THEIR REFUSAL TO
EVER NEGOTIATE IN GOOD FAITH,
YOU KNOW, ANYPLACE, ANYTIME
INSPECTIONS, THAT WOULD BE A
PRETTY GOOD START.
MEANWHILE, STILL LITTLE CLARITY
FROM TEAM BIDEN AMID A WAVE OF
CYBERATTACKS AGAINST U.S. CYBER
INFRASTRUCTURE.
BUT DON'T WORRY, BIDEN SAID
"AFTER HE TOOK HIS TIME, ORDERED
HIS ICE CREAM I'M LATE BECAUSE
THEY WERE JUST BRIEFING ME
AND -- WHAT AM I GOING TO DO
ABOUT IT -- THEY MADE ME WRITE
IT DOWN.
LET ME READ IT.
I WILL PERSONALLY DELIVER THE
MESSAGE TO VLADIMIR PUTIN
HIMSELF.
WHEN ASKED ABOUT HIS PLANS TO
SEND THE RUSSIAN LEADER,
WHATEVER THAT MEANS, ANYWAY,
THEN LOOK AT CHINA TONIGHT.
REMEMBER RUSSIA AND CHINA ARE
PROVIDING IRANIANS WEAPONS TO
FIGHT THEIR PROXY WAR IN THE
MIDDLE EAST.
IF THAT IS A DANGEROUS TRIFECTA
THERE.
BUT IN CHINA, BEIJING IS MAKING
MORE THREATS.
THEIR GEOGRAPHICAL AMBITIONS ARE
ON FULL DISPLAY.
NOW THEY ARE THREATENING THE
UNITED STATES, THEY ARE
THREATENING WAR TO ANY U.S.
ACTION DEFENDING TAIWAN.
THEY ARE PLANNING ON
REUNIFICATION WITH TAIWAN AND
ASK YOURSELF, WHAT WEIGHT TO ANY
OF BIDEN'S WORDS CARRY WHEN THEY
SEE HIS STRUGGLES, WHEN THEY SEE
HIS LACK OF MENTAL ACUITY,
ALERTNESS, AWARENESS, AND WHEN
THEY SEE HIS LACK OF A CLEAR
FOREIGN POLICY VISION.
HERE KNOW WHAT THE REACTION,
LOUISIANA SENATOR JOHN KENNEDY.
ALL RIGHT, SO YOU'VE GOT
CYBERATTACKS FROM RUSSIA,
IRANIANS ENRICHING AGAIN.
YOU'VE GOT RUSSIA AND CHINA
PROVIDING THE IRANIANS ARMS AND
CHINA IS NOW SAYING YEAH, WE'RE
GOING FOR REUNIFICATION JUST
LIKE THEY SHUT DOWN HONG KONG,
IT'S ABOUT TO GET WORSE AND IF
YOU MESS WITH US WE HAVE
1.5 BILLION PEOPLE AND WE WILL
TAKE OUT YOUR MILITARY SITES.
WHAT'S JOE GOING TO DO, SENATOR?
>> I DON'T UNDERSTAND
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S FOREIGN
POLICY.
HE KEEPS TALKING ABOUT
RULE-BASED ORDER.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS.
NOBODY IS OPPOSED TO RULES-BASED
ORDER.
THAT WOULD BE LIKE OPPOSING
GOLDEN RETRIEVER'S, BUT DON'T
KNOW WHAT IT MEANS.
THE QUESTION HE NEEDS TO BE
ASKING IS WHAT DOES AMERICAN
WANT FROM ITS FOREIGN POLICY.
I KNOW WHAT I WANT.
I WANT A FOREIGN POLICY THAT
HELPS CREATE AN AMERICA IN WHICH
PEOPLE CAN CONTINUE TO PROSPER
AND AMERICANS CAN LIVE THEIR
LIVES AS THEY SEE FIT AND AS A
MORAL AND SUPPLE ON FOR THAT FOR
EVERY OTHER COUNTRY.
HOW DO YOU ACHIEVE THAT?
TO RULES.
NUMBER ONE, DON'T BE A BULLY,
AND NUMBER TWO, DON'T TOLERATE
BULLIES.
I'M TALKING ABOUT IRAN AND
RUSSIA AND CHINA.
HOW DO YOU ACHIEVE THAT?
WEAKNESS INVITES THE WARS.
THE RECENT BULLIES -- THE REASON
BULLIES FEAR US IS BECAUSE
AMERICA IS THE STRONGEST COUNTRY
MILITARILY IN ALL OF HUMAN
HISTORY.
WE ARE ALSO THE WEALTHIEST
COUNTRY IN ALL OF HUMAN HISTORY.
WE NEED TO MAINTAIN IT.
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS UNDERMINING
IT.
HE'S PROPOSING MASSIVE TAX
INCREASES, WHICH WILL DESTROY
WEALTH.
HE SPENT AND IS PROPOSING TO
SPEND TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT
WE DON'T HAVE ON THINGS WE DON'T
NEED.
NUMBER TWO.
HE IS TO CUT THE MILITARY.
WE NEED TO BE INCREASING OUR
MILITARY SPENDING.
NUMBER THREE, SIX MONTHS AGO,
SEAN, WE WERE ON A GLIDE PATH AS
A COUNTRY TO ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE.
PRESIDENT BIDEN STOPPED THAT FOR
SURE.
NUMBER FOUR, HE NEEDS TO TELL
HIS PEOPLE TO STOP APOLOGIZING
FOR AMERICA.
WE HAVE NOTHING TO APOLOGIZE
FOR.
WE ARE NOT PERFECT, BUT WE ARE
GOOD.
WHEN HIS U.N. AMBASSADOR AND HER
FIRST SPEECH TO EVERY COUNTRY IN
THE WORLD AND AT THE U.N. IN
NEW YORK SAYS THAT WHITE
SUPREMACY IS WOVEN THROUGH THE
FABRIC OF AMERICA'S FOUNDING
PRINCIPLES, THAT'S NOT HELPFUL.
YOU MENTIONED RUSSIA.
THERE IS WHAT WE NEED TO DO WITH
RUSSIA.
PRESIDENT BIDEN TOLD PUTIN TO
STOP THE CYBERATTACKS.
THE CYBERATTACKS HAVE CONTINUED.
HE NEEDS TO HIT PUTIN WITH A
SERIOUS CYBER ATTACK.
TWO WRONGS DON'T MAKE IT RIGHT
BUT THEY DO MAKE IT EVEN.
NUMBER TWO, HE NEEDS TO READ --
PRESIDENT BIDEN NEEDS TO
REIMPOSE SANCTIONS ON THE NORTH
STREAM 2.
YOU MENTIONED IRAN.
IRAN KNOWS WHAT WE WANT.
NO NUCLEAR WARHEAD, NO MISSILE
TECHNOLOGY, AND STOP EXPORTING
TERRORISM.
PRESIDENT BIDEN NEEDS TO GIVE
IRAN SIX MONTHS.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO TALK WITH
THEM BUT NO MORE THAN SIX MONTHS
AND IF IRAN DOESN'T AGREE WITH
ADDITIONAL SANCTIONS,
PRESIDENT BIDEN NEEDS TO HIT
THEM SO HARD THAT EVEN GOOGLE
CAN'T FIND THEM.
CHINA --
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU THIS.
>> GO AHEAD.
>> Sean: PUT IN GETS A WAIVER
TO BUILD HIS PIPELINE
SIMULTANEOUSLY CANCELING JOBS AT
THE KEYSTONE PIPELINE.
THE IRANIANS, HE LIFTS THE
SANCTIONS AND TO BE VERY HONEST,
I THINK IT NOW BECOMES A PIVOTAL
QUESTION, IS THERE A GOOD CHANCE
THAT THE 1.5 BILLION DOLLAR BANK
OF CHINA DEAL THAT 0-EXPERIENCE
HUNTER GOT MIGHT HAVE
COMPROMISED THE BIDEN FAMILY
WITH CHINA AND WHAT WILL JOE DO
WHEN THE REUNIFICATION WITH
TAIWAN COMES, SENATOR AND MY
LAST PART IS, 57% OF AMERICANS,
50% OF INDEPENDENTS, A THIRD OF
DEMOCRATS BELIEVE JOE IS NOT
RUNNING THE SHOW.
DO YOU BELIEVE HE'S RUNNING THE
SHOW?
[INDISCERNIBLE].
>> I -- I -- I DON'T KNOW.
I JUDGE THEM AND BY HIS ACTIONS.
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS RESPONSIBLE
WHETHER HE'S RUNNING THE SHOW OR
NOT.
AND I CAN TELL YOU WITH RESPECT
TO CHINA, IT'S ALSO TRUE WITH
IRAN AND RUSSIA, WEAKNESS
INVITES THE WOLVES.
HE WANTS TO GET PRESIDENT XI'S
ATTENTION AND CHINA,
PRESIDENT BIDEN SHOULD DO TWO
THINGS IMMEDIATELY.
NUMBER ONE, HE SHOULD NEGOTIATE
AND SIGN A TRADE AGREEMENT WITH
TAIWAN.
WOW.
THAT WILL GET CHINA'S ATTENTION.
AND NUMBER TWO, HE NEEDS TO
PUBLICLY BACK AUSTRALIA.
AUSTRALIA HAS TRIED TO STAND UP
TO CHINA.
CHINA IS BOYCOTTING ALL
AUSTRALIAN GOODS AND AUSTRALIAN
SENDS A LOT OF ITS EXPORTS TO
CHINA.
WE NEED TO COME TO THE AID OF
AUSTRALIA AND WE NEED TO SPEAK
LOUDLY AND CLEARLY AND TELL THE
EUROPEAN UNION WE EXPECT THEIR
HELP.
>> Sean: I DON'T SEE -- I
AGREE WITH MUCH OF YOUR
ANALYSIS.
I DON'T SEE IT HAPPENING.
>> THERE'S ONE OTHER THING WE
CAN DO, SEAN.
>> Sean: LAST WORD, GO AHEAD.
>> THIS IS GOING TO BE
CONTROVERSIAL.
WE NEED -- AMERICA NEEDS TO
VACCINATE THE WORLD.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO TAKE THE
VACCINE IF YOU DON'T WANT IT,
BUT IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO
AND IT WILL MAKE FRIENDS ALL
OVER THE WORLD AND EVERY VILE,
EVERY SYRINGE NEEDS TO HAVE
"MADE IN THE USA" ON IT.
>> Sean: I THINK FOR THE SAKE
OF THE WORLD TO GIVE PEOPLE THAT
OPTION, THAT SHOWS ONCE AGAIN --
I WOULD ARGUE WE SHOWED IT ALL
THROUGHOUT OUR HISTORY, WE ABUSE
POWER LESS THAN ANY GREAT
COUNTRY.
WE ADVANCE THE HUMAN CONDITION,
WE SHARE SUCH INVENTION AND
INNOVATION SCIENTIFICALLY,
MEDICALLY, WITH OTHER COUNTRIES
FOR FREE.
>> LET'S SHOW THE WORLD -